one area of town that you were talking
about that got hit hard in particular
was the east side of town
several power poles were knocked down
right near russell and boulder highway
that's where we find 8 news now reporter
sasha loftis joining us live there with
more
sasha brian quite a lot of damage in
this area as you said multiple power
lines
knocked down i'll give you a look at
just how many an entire row of these
power lines just completely snapped
in half here along boulder highway right
in front of the boulder
ranch development now we saw three
microbursts
two in henderson one in summerlin today
this here is video of the one in
henderson sent to us by giovanni falcone
it packed 60 mile an hour winds now
microbursts are of course very dangerous
as it's really an isolated area
that gets hit hard in a short amount of
time they're also rare the last time we
saw one was on july 20
2018 three years ago almost to the day
we did speak to a woman who was really
in her car when the storm hit she said
it felt
like a hurricane when it happened just
really a scary experience
now in extreme cases microbursts have
been known to bring down planes
so it's really important to take these
seriously now back out here live this is
just one
of many areas hit hard again these power
lines just completely
snapped in half you can see they're down
blocking this part of the road blocking
an entrance to this neighborhood so just
important to be aware here in the
southeast valley and all
around the city now we are going to send
it over to joe muller he is also
standing by
covering weather for us today he is live
in henderson
with the very latest on what it's
looking like there joe
yes we are at the royal grande sports
complex not too far from sunset station
here in henderson and this park has
a substantial amount of damage here i
want to give everybody a look real quick
these are bleachers that are normally
bolted into the ground here you can see
they were actually picked up
and actually it's bent the metal is bent
from the strong wind that
came through this area and then if we
actually step back here just a little
bit more
the tarps all on top of this sports
complex above all the bleachers that
protect people from the sun usually
those are all torn off and they're just
seeing a lot of damage like this and to
my left here even
trees are all on the ground crews are
going through here still assessing all
the damage and they're actually
trying to clean up what they can
normally there is practice
on these fields this is the softball
field and the baseball fields here at
the park those have all been canceled
from tonight and through the weekend so
crews can actually go through here and
see what sort of damage there is we are
going to point out
there is some structural damage at this
softball field here you can see the
fence is down on the ground back there
and the scoreboard
actually was uh it was the wind was so
hard it pushed that over so crews are
going to have to come out here
and repair that but we did speak to a
city official here just a short time ago
who said
electricity is still out here at the
park and said that the
shed where the workers actually go and
park there their vehicle is damaged so
they actually send some crews home
because it's so
humid that they didn't want the crew
staying here without the air
conditioning but they are still going
through this park assessing the damage
but if you drive around this area
several streetlights are out there
asking people to be careful
if you are coming to some of the street
lights around the arroyo grande sports
complex area
and they're asking everybody just be
slow and be safe i'll send it back to
you in the studio